bonjour à tous cette semaine je vous
emmène en bretagne c'est ici dans ce
petit village au coeur du morbihan que
l'on expérimente le tout écolo maisons
en bois cantina bio et même la piscine
du centre de vacances ici tout est fait
pour préserver l'environnement et bien
sûr ses démarches à un coup alors une
maison écolo revient tel vraiment plus
cher qu'une maison traditionnelle
comment construire en utilisant le moins
de pétrole possible
réponse dans ce nouveau numéro des pieds
sur terre
michel s'est installé à silfiac il ya
six mois dans son ancienne vie elle
était comptable en région parisienne au
moment de prendre sa retraite
elle a choisi de s'installer ici dans ce
lotissement 100% écolo
les poireaux de la salade de betteraves
et cette maison bioclimatique michel l'a
voulu en bois en fait j'ai voulu une
maison saine une maison je me sens bien
dedans où je ne vais pas respirer
les peintures qui nous crée des
allergies donc j'ai utilisé des
peintures scène des enduits sein des
produits qui existait sur mon agent il
ya longtemps et que les gens utilisaient
je me chauffe donc avec ce poêle à bois
il ya une usine pas loin d'ici qui
récupère en fait dans les scieries de la
sueur de loi que je vais mettre dans le
poêle c'est sûr en fait elle n'est pas
traitée c'est à dire qu'en fait il
récupère relation au moment où le sieur
coupe les planches dans le tronc d'arbre
fait parce qu'une balazs de récupération
c'est de la récupération tout à fait et
vous pouvez soupeser vous allez voir que
c'est lourd 1 comme une peluche tout à
fait et la pierre en fait c'est une
pierre ollaire qui va accumuler la
chaleur donc le poil en fait devient
chaud hein
et il va restituer la chaleur en fait
pendant au moins douze heures il n'y a
pas d'autre d'autres enfin je crois
à l'extérieur une gouttière permet de
récupérer les eaux de pluie
elles sont ensuite stocké dans une cuve
toutes les eaux de pluie qui arrive sur
le toit rives paris côtière et puis
viennent directement par une tranchée
qui amène l'eau ici une fois filtrer
l'eau peut être réutilisé j'ai eu un
petit système ici sur mon robinet
indécis de l'eau normale sans relâche et
puis ici j'ai un doute robinet ou en
fait ça ne filtre tout un tas de petites
particules qui serait peut-être pas
bonne à boire déjà et puis pour pour
baigner là leur public
les futurs voisins de michel ont eux
aussi choisi du bois du bois produit
localement en bretagne et en normandie
j'ai vraiment et architectes il vient
vérifier l'avancée des travaux
dans le fond on prend où il n'ya pas de
décrocher sur tout ça on va isoler la
maison on va la rendre scène et la
chaleur que vous allez produire ne va
pas partir à l'extérieur elle va rester
dans cette maison
ces principes denys arcand
ce sol c'est ce qu'on appelle une belle
chose chambre chaud chaud chaud chantier
assez de la chaux qui viennent des
carrières est un mélange de chanvre
enfin deux conquis émis en copeaux et
qui sert d'isolant pour isoler la chap
c'est à dire qu'on va isoler le sol
puisqu'on va isoler la totalité de
l'envelope de la maison il ya un risque
de déperdition par le sol de la chaleur
qui va s'accumuler
donc on se risque et fait bondir en a
nulle part cette isolation qui est faite
directement dans la salle la dalle en
elle-même est isolant et ouvriers
utilisent une autre innovation technique
de la laine de bois un isolant aussi
efficace que les matériaux classiques
mais non tout lure mais problème
aujourd'hui ces maisons en bois ou au
pas y reviennent à la construction un
peu plus cher qu'une maison
traditionnelle
exprimant la maison va vous revenir
entre 10 et 15% plus cher qu'une maison
dite traditionnelle en parpaings
maintenant cet investissement va être
très très vite rentabilisé par
d'isolation que vous allez avoir dans
cette maison et surtout vous allez vivre
dans un habitat kesang 10 à 15 % plus
cher et non pas difficile à tours ça
aujourd'hui accessible à tout le monde
avec les aides de l'état
vous avez les 13 0% pour la construction
écologique ou même dans la rénovation
au final cette maison de 90 m² coûtera
130 mille euros terrain compris mais les
terrains justement ont été bradées 12
euros le mètre carré
une décision de cet homme serge moëlo
pour attirer de nouveaux visages dans sa
commune de 400 habitants le maire a eu
une idée vendre la terre à un prix
faible mais exigées en échange les
constructions le plus écolo possible pas
de parpaings pas d'ouverture en pvc pas
de béton voilà sauf pour les fondations
évidemment pas de goudron enfin bon
voilà mais les matériaux qu'on interdise
c'est qu'il y avait toujours une
solution plus intéressante
écologiquement au même prix en fait
voilà donc on voulait pas non plus
imposer d
les contraintes financières en fait aux
gens quoi nous on a trouvé beaucoup de
billets pour faire en sorte que les
maisons ne coûte pas trop cher aux gens
par exemple dans ce lotissement notons
on a autorisé l'autoconstruction sas et
c'est assez rare aussi dans les
lotissements que d'autoriser tout ou
partie en fait pour tout ou partie de la
maison
une de l'auto construction et puis en
fait ça va la concurrence va faire en
sorte que ça se normalise aussi parce qu
en fait à l'origine quand il y avait peu
de distributeurs de certains matériaux
ils pouvaient pratiquer les prix qu'ils
voulaient aujourd'hui aussi une
concurrence qui jours
donc voici la situation en fait de
traitement des eaux usées de l'ensemble
du bourg pour en fait c'est une
technique de lagunage on a un ensemble
de trois lagune
cette première la une fait un premier
traitement et ce sont les goûts et les
plantes situé au autour de ces lacunes
qui traite cette eau est ensuite il ya
ça passe dans un deuxième bassin ou
voilà il ya une deuxième opération qui
ce fait et au bout du compte
complètement à la sortie les eaux sont
parfaitement aux normes et parfaitement
correcte pour rejeter pour être rejetée
dans le milieu dans le milieu
ici ce sont les moutons qui
entretiennent les abords des champs
deschamps bien sûr bordés d'éoliennes
installées il y a deux ans et quatre
éoliennes permettent d'alimenter en
électricité deux villages comme silfiac
et ce petit hameau d'irréductibles écolo
a même attiré un centre de vacances 100%
vers le premier du genre en france
vivez et n'est en fait d'une réflexion
sur quels seraient les vacances dans 20
30 ans donc c'est comme ça qu'est né ce
village là 100% écolo dans son
fonctionnement et dans sa réalisation
et donc on arrive au premier bâtiment
d'hébergement qu'on appelle le bosquet
est donc le deuxième se trouve derrière
et c'est des bâtiments qui ont été
réalisés au nord donc comme je vous
disais hpe haute qualité
environnementale la chaudière bois est
ici donc le boire et livrer ici il est
stocké donc dans cette danse est qu ici
c'est du bois plaquette qu'on peut voir
là en fait c'est ça qu'on appelle du
bois plaquettes et je vais vous montrer
maintenant où il arrive dans la
chaudière donc le bois arrive d'en bas
il est remonté ici par une vis donc le
bois plaquette qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
et donc il va arriver dans le foyer ici
c'est là qu'il va être rude et produire
de la chaleur qui va chauffer de l'eau
on
mais ce dont guillaume chalet est le
plus fier c'est cette piscine écologique
on voit la zone naturelle domaniale donc
les gens les vacanciers les résidences
se baigne donc ici ici vous avez le
bassin de baignade est donc à côté du
bassin de baignade
vous avez donc de ce côté ci la zone de
filtration les eaux donc de la piscine
sont filtrées ici par des plantes et
également par des roches volcaniques qui
sont en profondeur sur 4 mètres de
profondeur en fait les qui vont
participer à la filtration
on a 150 plants en gros dans ce bassin
des joncs des iris les roseaux alors ils
viennent juste d'être coupé puisqu'on
arrive en hiver donc en fait c'est la
période où on les coupe pour qu'il
reparte de plus belle l'année prochaine
mais donc donc voilà c'est ses portes
qui participent à la filtration de la
zone naturelle de baignade
oui
et le tout écolo ça marche alors que
l'école de silfiac ne comptait qu'une
vingtaine d'élèves en 1989
ils sont aujourd'hui plus de 70 voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis pour nous retrouver
sur notre site internet publicsenat.fr
à très bientôt et surtout n'oubliez pas
garder les pieds sur terre